what do an icy despot and a
crustacean-themed conqueror have in
common game of thrones and house of the
dragon viewers may notice some shared
traits spoilers for house of the dragon
ahead
the ending of the second episode of
house of the dragon introduces viewers
to cragus drajar also known as crab
feeder whose nickname tells you
everything you need to know about his
preferred method of execution and body
disposal a high ranking member of the
triarchy crab feeder has conquered the
strategically important step stones
islands as a result the era's finest
seafarer and reigning master of ships
lord corliss velarion isn't very happy
i will not have driftmark beggared while
our king idles himself with feasts and
balls and tawnies the sea snake forms an
alliance with disgraced damon targaryen
and in episode 3 they face off with crab
feeders forces on the stepstones in a
desperate bid to get the win before
reinforcements come in damon hatches a
daring plan to use himself as bait and
pretend to surrender to draw crab feeder
out from the caves he uses to avoid
dragonfire against all odds a desperate
maneuver works and after a thrilling
battle sequence daemon chases crab peter
down and kills him with his ravaged
features and golden face mask crab
beater is a very memorable looking guy
there's a time skip of three years in
the third episode of house of the dragon
and crab peter has been holding the
stepstones that whole time even so he
seems to go down easily when the time
comes grabbed reader's quick end has
some comparing him to the game of
thrones villain the night king and not
in a very good way they're both visually
interesting and super threatening
villains who mostly just stand around
looking creepy while everyone else does
the majority of the fighting and then
when the time comes for them to die
they're both dispatched fairly quickly
apart from the fact that crab peter
isn't a supernatural threat there's of
course one significant difference by the
time arya stark stabs the night king to
death in game of thrones the villain has
been a looming threat since season 4. as
such while the leader of the white
walkers does go down over the course of
a single episode at least he's been
around for a while
what does he want
an endless knight
he wants to erase this world
crab feeder on the other hand only gets
that ominous intro at the end of episode
two the show then fast forwards through
all of his cool moments of which there
must have been many considering that he
seems to have been successfully holding
the stepstones for several years
we don't even see his gruesome death
scene damon by sex crab feeder
off-screen
one would assume house of the dragon is
trying to avoid making the mistakes many
fans think game of thrones made in its
final season with author george rr
martin's increased involvement and the
benefit of hindsight it's easy to
imagine that the prequel will look to
steer clear of the events that led to
rampant criticism of the last few
episodes of game of thrones the night
king swift and for some anti-climactic
downfall after seasons of build-up seems
like the kind of thing house of the
dragon wouldn't be willing to touch with
a 10-foot pole by introducing crab
feeder in a big bad fashion and doing
away with the character after one
episode of hectic battle also the dragon
may deliberately be introducing similar
seeming storylines but tweaking them so
they have a different impact it's also
entirely possible that house of the
dragon is using the shorthand of a
similar storyline as a means to build up
daemon as a shrewd operator still it's
pretty strange that the show's writers
seemingly chose to call back to the
original show's least loved era unless
it's unintentional which could indicate
a whole different set of issues
[Music]